this morning we're highlighting some new
fall releases amazon books editorial
director sarah gilman joins us right now
good morning sarah good morning all
right so let's jump right into it you
say there's a book that could be one of
the best of the year which one is it so
good i'm so excited about all of these
books i loved celeste eng's new book
it's called our missing hearts so she
wrote the book little fires everywhere
that was turned into the popular hulu
adaptation it was the number one new
york times bestseller and this new book
i think really takes her out of her
comfort zone as an author and it works
it is really i would say like one of my
favorite books of the year if not in
multiple years it is about a son looking
for his mother in a dystopian america
where children are taken away from
their parents if the government deems
them to be unfit or unpatriotic and a
lot of asian-american parents i read
this book right in the wake of the
salman rushdie attack and it was so
poignant to think about the importance
of freedom of speech and just the power
of art and expression one of my
colleagues said this was fiction as
revolution and i think that's such a
good description oh wow that sounds
powerful it's so good like chill's good
really okay yeah all right i'm in uh you
also have a book about a young
immigrant's memoir what's making this
one so special for you this is another
chills book it's such it's a great fall
for reading i'm just going to say that
this is selenia solido by javier zamora
this is a memoir so xavier zamora is a
young poet and he's writing about when
he was nine years old he migrated from
el salvador to the united states he was
supposed to be on a two-week journey and
he was going to meet his parents who
lived in the states already but the
journey ended up taking over two months
and he was alone he wasn't with any
family he was with a group of strangers
and you're reading this and you just
like you feel the dust from the desert
you feel thirsty it's just so visceral
wow and i just i read it and i feel like
as a mother myself and an american a
human being this is it's required
reading okay uh we also have a debut
thriller by an author who is in real
life was an autopsy technician yes those
gore wow it sounds like yes and also the
co-host of the popular podcast morbid
it's elena erkhart and this is the
butcher and the ren now my mom is a
sweet lady from ohio and she loves the
most morbid tv shows and books she can
get her hands on you know the type like
i'm like
shout out to your mom
actually most women are really into
crime such a weird thing anyway this is
a book for all of them all of you people
that like morbid things it's about a
medical examiner that is helping to find
a serial killer who performs medical
experiments on his victims it is scary
it is a read in one sitting kind of book
all right there's something for
non-fiction lovers yes non-fiction
lovers it's called like comment
subscribe it's about youtube's rise by
mark bergen and bergen captures this
cultural moment where social media was
really ascendant and the way that we
were all consuming tv was just blowing
up right and he looks at the early days
of youtube and their rat infested
offices to like this tremendous growth
that they've realized today i feel like
i'm my three-year-old who's asking me to
watch unboxing videos on youtube and
like that's how much they've infiltrated
our culture and this is in this new wave
of books that are kind of investigative
reporting on successful tech companies
that's interesting the author of the
best-selling memoir inheritance has
something new danny shapiro this is her
first novel in 15 years it is so
beautiful it starts in the summer of
1985 three teenagers who have been
drinking get into a car and they're in
an accident and one of them dies
and it reminds me of the ripple effect
like dropping a pebble into a pond and
it reverberates on it's this one choice
that a child makes and it just goes
through generations you see how it
impacts them it's just so beautifully
written i'm taking this one guys okay i
need the butcher in the ring
i think that's behind you
all right sarah gelman thank you i can't
oh you got i saw it already it's mine